good morning hank it's tuesday a while
back i was asked to host a book event
with joe biden in general i dislike
political memoirs but i was very moved
by this particular book which is about
grief and what it actually means to
serve the public
i guess i should pause here and say this
is a political video and i know some
people in comments would be like when
did vlogbrothers get so political
the answer is that we've been talking
about politics since like mid-january
2007 but i understand the concern and
anyway to be honest i did not have a
particularly strong opinion about joe
biden
i just liked the book it was like sad
and human and openly conflicted
in a way that political memoirs rarely
are so right i fly to i don't know
somewhere like st
louis to do the q a and i'm sitting
backstage in some little room editing a
crash course script when someone comes
in and says would you like to meet vice
president biden and i'm like
sure at this point in my life i had
become accustomed to people saying kind
things to me that they didn't actually
mean because like even very modest
amounts of fame can serve as a sort of
filter that distorts the way people look
at you
like once in the early 2000s i met the
guy who played gilligan on gilligan's
island and for some reason i boarded out
i love gilligan's island even though i
had never seen an episode of the program
which became a real problem when he
responded thank you so much what's your
favorite episode
anyway i went in to see joe biden and he
said he and his family really loved the
fault in our stars and that it was
helpful to them as they were processing
his son's cancer diagnosis and i said
thank you
and then he asked me about esther and i
started talking about her
and i noticed that there were tears in
his eyes even though we only spent a few
minutes together i was very
struck by the fact that he wanted to
talk about esther more than he wanted to
talk about like the success of the book
or the movie or whatever
so then some security-ish people came
and said it was time to go on stage and
as we were walking toward the stage
biden got asked for an autograph by one
of the stage hands whose name was i
think
tim and they quickly got into a very
intense conversation
and then the security-ish people were
like we really got to go on stage and so
biden said to tim
will you be here afterwards and tim was
like yeah that's how stagehanding works
and then biden and i went on stage and
did our hour-long q a thing and the
moment it was over he went backstage
and said tim and they continued their
conversation and in fact
we're still talking when i left for the
hotel joe biden gave me
the exact same level of attention that
he gave
tim and i have met a lot of famous and
powerful people in my life
and that is very rare so look i think
biden's plans for tackling the kovid
pandemic are far more convincing than
trump's i think biden's climate change
proposals are serious while trumps are
literally non-existent and so on but
this isn't an election only about policy
positions i mean for the first time in
over 120 years the republican party
released no new platform this election
cycle
no document outlining their plan for
tackling issues from
taxation to covid the trump
administration has no comprehensive
responses to these issues because their
idea of governance is not about policy
it's about populism trump seeks to
establish a clear us
and to clear them and then argues that
only a vote for trump can prevent
them from taking over and ruining
america i reject
that idea of governance we are not going
to us versus them
our way out of covid or climate change
or anything else
i think joe biden would be a
fundamentally different kind of
president a president who will listen
carefully and with empathy who won't try
to concentrate power but will instead
build and support teams of experts
and a president who will lead with
decency
and humanity hank i'll see you on friday